- Hi, everyone.
Sal Khan here from Kahn Academy.
Welcome to our Daily Homeroom live stream
which is really just a way
of having interesting conversations
and staying connected during
this time of school closures
and social distancing.
Before we get into what I
expect to be a very exciting
and interesting
conversation with our guest,
I will give my standard announcement.
We are not for profit,
we're only able to exist
because of philanthropic donations.
I wanna give a special shout
out to several corporations
that have stepped up
in the last few weeks,
especially as our costs have gone up.
Our usage has been about 2.5, three X
of what it typically is
during this COVID crisis.
You can imagine server costs,
and we're trying to increase our programs
and content for a lot of folks.
So special thanks to Bank of America,
Google.org, Novartis, AT&T, and Fastly,
and our many other supporters
who have been supporting
Kahn Academy through the years
that have really put us in a position
to be able to do the work we're doing now.
We still are running at a deficit.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about making
a donation to Kahn Academy.
With that out of the way, I'm excited
to introduce our guest today,
David Leonhardt who's a writer
for the "New York Times".
Good to see you, David.
- Good to see you, Sal.
Thanks for having me.
- No, it's an honor.
And you know, you've been
writing for a little while
and you're doing a lot this summer
or the spring on inequality.
So what got you interested in inequality?
- I guess, my background
when I was in school,
my favorite subject was math,
but I also really liked working
on the student newspaper.
So I think to some extent,
it's just a reflective
of this long-time interest
that I've always had
of describing the world
around me using numbers,
and then doing it for a general audience,
rather than an academic audience.
But then as I became a journalist
over the last 25 years,
I really came to think this was one
of the most important things,
really along with climate change,
going on in our country.
The fact that the living
standards of most Americans
don't track anymore with
the statistics you read
on what our economy as a whole is doing.
And that really creates
all kinds of problems.
And in a way, that's
really what inequality is.
And so I think it affects
everything from politics
to obviously, living standards,
to education, to health.
We clearly see it playing out now
in the coronavirus.
And so it's one of these
things in which everywhere
I looked around, or almost everywhere,
I saw inequality kind of as an explanation
for a lot of the huge
trends in our society.
- And I wanna look at some
of the charts in a little bit
from some of your op-ed pieces,
and some of your articles you've written.
But you know, just as a, maybe this will
be a naive question,
but just as a level set.
You know, in society,
some level of inequality
one might argue is inevitable.
Is there a certain
threshold of when inequality
becomes too much?
And you said that it
could lead to problems.
What type of problems do you think
large inequalities could lead to?
- Yeah, I think that's
an important level set.
I mean, I think not only is
some degree of inequality
probably inevitable, but I
would go so far as to say
it's probably desirable.
The societies that have tried
to get rid of inequality entirely
have failed, essentially.
And probably the best,
most tangible modern example is in China
in which in the 1970s, China discovered
that it was really having a
hard time getting anything done
because they were insisting that everyone
was gonna have the same no matter what.
People weren't farming their
lands in efficient ways.
And the great sort of
economic revolution in China
was lead by Deng Xiaoping
in which he tried to move, essentially,
toward a system that was
going to inevitably result
in more inequality.
But it also lifted almost
everyone's living standards.
The problem is was when inequality
just gets too, too big.
And we've seen this happen a number
of times throughout history.
It happened in parts
of the late 19th century in this country.
It happened in the 1920s.
And when inequality gets too big,
you have many problems.
But I'll highlight two.
One is that the people who
are amassing huge amounts
of society's resources end up being able
to essentially set the rules
through the amount of influence
they have over both the
economy and politics
to make sure they never
lose what they have.
And two, is you end up
with a lot of people
whose living standards just
aren't rising very rapidly
because you have such a large
share of society's resources
going to such a small portion of society.
And you know, it's subjective
about when it's too much.
But when you look at just how
much inequality has increased
over the last 30, 40, 50
years in this society.
It's been so extreme
that I think you either have to say,
"Well boy, something was
terribly wrong in our society
"in the '50s and '60s
and it was too equal,
"or something is wrong
now, and it's too unequal."
It's hard to really imagine
that both can work well.
- And there's this fairness argument
which you make very well just now
that at some point, money
to some degree is power
and then that power could
be to keep more money.
And then obviously, there's a fairness
that it just gets at some point unfair.
But are there other implications?
I mean, if it gets too unequal,
the things like the French Revolution,
or I mean, is it just the
nature of our democracy
become less stable?
- I think it does.
There's a fascinating book
by a couple of political scientists
in which they look at why nations fail.
I believe that's actually
the title of the book.
And they argue that over
the course of history,
inequality is the key, not the only,
but is the key reason
why societies decline.
That when basically you have societies
in which the mass of
people are not enjoying
rising living standards, it can lead
to political instability.
It also can end up being
a real waste of talent.
If large sections of your society
are closed off from opportunity,
or even if they're not
completely closed off,
if opportunity's so difficult
that most of the people in those sections
of society will not be
allowed to escape it,
you end up missing out on
huge amounts of talent.
There's a recent research
paper called "Lost Einsteins",
that tries to quantify some of the costs
of our rising inequality.
And the idea is that there
are probably hundreds
of kids today who might
reach the very, very top
of science and other fields
if only they had better opportunities
than they do.
And so there really are,
even if you can't predict
when those bills will come due,
or exactly how they'll come due,
there really are long-term costs.
And I think even people
who are on the happy end
on many of the inequality trends
should have some reason to worry
that in the long-term, it
could lead to a society
that functions much less helpfully
than one where living
standards are rising broadly
for most of the population.
- And let's make that a
little bit more tangible.
Philippe, if we could
bring up that first chart
which comes from one of David's articles
that shows inequality, or actually,
it shows per capita GDP over
the last several decades,
and how the different groups.
David, could you just
explain what's going on here?
It might be a little bit small
depending on how large
people's screens are,
but what do we see here?
- Yeah, so I love this chart.
And so I think the place
to start is exactly
where you said we should start
which is per capita GDP.
So that's that dark black line
with per capita GDP pointing at it.
So that's basically over, since 1980,
that's the cumulative percentage change
in how much our economy
produces every year.
So you take the total value
of everything we've produced,
all the services, all
the goods, everything,
and then you divide it
by the number of people.
That's per capita.
And you say, essentially,
if we divided our GDP perfectly evenly
which again, I don't recommend,
that's what would be happening.
And so you can see it's really rising
quite nicely in some ways, right?
I mean, it's nearly an increase of 100%.
So I'm sure most of the listeners
know would be a doubling, okay?
So it hasn't quite doubled since 1980.
This is adjusted for inflation,
but it's come pretty close to doubling.
But then, you kind of get under that,
and you look at what's happened
to each economic group.
And you look at the bottom 50%.
Well, their incomes have risen.
They're making more money
than they were in 1980,
but they haven't risen that much.
- [Sal] And to be clear,
this is all an inflation adjusted.
So it's not just, you know, people say,
"Oh, things were cheaper in 1950,"
but this is adjusted
arguably for inflation.
This is real income.
- This is adjusted for inflation.
And there are fights about
exactly about how to do it,
and is it perfectly done,
or is it overstated or understated.
And those are good, interesting fights.
But the bottom line is if
you adjust for inflation,
what you're really trying capture
is the experience, people's lives.
The fact that today, something, you know,
what's a Big Mac today?
Five bucks?
The fact that it might have
cost two bucks in the past,
I hope I'm not wrong about that.
I don't eat a lot of Big Macs,
that doesn't actually show
any significant difference
between it over time.
So you adjust for that.
So what you see here is
that for the bottom 50%
or the middle 40%, things have risen.
You know when people say
that the middle class
today is making less money
than it did in the past,
I think that's wrong if you're looking
at the long-term past.
But the increases have been modest.
And here, I think, is an important thing.
They have been much
smaller than the increases
you would expect based
from what our economy
has been producing.
You then move up to what for shorthand,
I call the upper middle class,
the 90th to 99th percentile.
You've got a lot of doctors in there.
You've got lawyers.
You've got university professors.
You've gotta a lot of
professionals, right?
Their income has tracked
actually quite closely
with per capita GDP.
Not everyone's, but as a group.
And then when you get to the top 1%,
and really to the top of the top 1%,
the top .01%, you see
that they're on a completely
different trajectory.
Their incomes are
tripling, are quintupling.
And so when you see this, I
think it helps you realize
some of the frustrations that people have.
People feel like, "Wait a second,
"even if I make more money
than my grandparents did,
"than my parents did,"
which some people do
and some people don't,
it sure doesn't feel like
I'm keeping up with society
as a whole.
And they're right about that.
And it's not just absolute changes
that people judge their lives on.
There's a rich psychological
research that shows
it's relative changes as well.
I mean, put it this way, Sal,
if you and I worked at a
company where profits doubled,
and you and I got a 10%
raise the previous year,
and we could look and see
a bunch of other workers
who got their pay tripled,
would we say, "Oh my
goodness, we're so happy
"we got a 10% raise"?
Or would we say, "Wait a second,
"this doesn't feel totally fair."
And I think that's how
a lot of Americans feel,
and they're right to feel that way.
- And before we get into potential causes
of these trends, I will ask,
and I'll play devil's
advocate a little bit
which is you know, there's this argument,
look, we have market forces, capitalism.
As you mentioned, you don't
want absolutely equal.
You want people to wanna
invest and take risk,
and that might lead to some,
and there's bad and good luck
that leads to some level of inequality.
Some would argue that, "Hey, look.
"At the end of the day, it
looks like everyone has improved
"in real terms.
"Why should we be so caught
up with the relative?"
Wouldn't you rather
have a world where everyone is improving,
maybe some more than others,
than a world where it's equal,
but we're not improving as much?
- Well, sure.
And I think part of the
answer to that question
is this is definitely better
than some alternatives
you could imagine.
It's better than a world in which GDP
wasn't rising at all.
It's better than a world in
which only a small percentage
of people are seeing an increase
and no one else is seeing
any kind of increase.
But when you look across
the relative comparisons,
it seems to me it really
requires a stretch to argue
that this is the natural outcome.
So one relative comparison
would be other high-income countries
over the same period.
They've also seen inequality rise,
but they haven't seen it rise
as much as the United States has.
So some other countries
have figured out ways
to have middle class pay rise more rapidly
and pay for low income workers
rise more rapidly than our pay has risen.
Maybe even more starkly,
those countries have also have had health
and life expectancy
grow substantially more
than the United States has.
So it seems like they're doing
something differently from us
and for much of the population,
most of the population,
it's working better.
Then you look at our own
country between the 1940s
and the 1970s.
By no means a perfect period,
a period in which opportunities for women
were highly constrained,
in which there was vicious,
often legally sanctioned racism
in which large numbers of
Americans couldn't vote.
Again, by no means a perfect period.
But when you look at these
same measures what you see
is that the pay of nearly every group,
if we look at this from
the '40s to the '80s,
'40s to the '70s, the pay of every group
would be much closer to that black line.
And not only that, but
the pay of the middle
would actually have
increased a little bit faster
than the pay at the top.
And so I think the burden,
the people who say this
is the natural outcome,
I think the burden is on them to explain,
well wait a second, why
is this a natural outcome
if it's not what the
United States used to have,
and it's not what many
other countries have had?
- And so given that, let's
go into possible reasons
for why this either is
happening around the globe
which it sounds like it has
been happening to some degree,
and in especially in the
case of the United States.
What do you think are the culprits here?
- So I think there are a few.
And I think they're all fascinating.
So I apologize, I'll be going through them
extremely quickly if you wanna dive
more into any one of them.
I think it's clear that globalization
is part of the cause here.
And there's a lot that's
wonderful about globalization.
I mean, for much of the late 20th century,
you had large parts of the world
that essentially weren't
competing in the global economy.
Either they were too poor,
or they were part of the Soviet Empire
and essentially weren't able
to compete in the economy.
Or they were Europe or Japan
which was essentially
destroyed by World War II,
both of which.
So some of it is this entrance of billions
of people into the global economy
which has increased competition,
particularly for certain kinds of labor,
and has created problems for people
in the more affluent world.
That's also wrapped up
with technological change
which plays a role there.
Then though, I think
there are a set of forces
we have essentially chosen.
- And just to make sure we all make sure
we understand those points
about globalization and technology
'cause I think they're similar.
You know, some would say,
okay there's competition around the world,
but why is that
disproportionately affecting
the lower incomes?
And your argument would be
technology and globalization.
You know, technology obviously
is now arguably a robot
or a computer might be able
to do parts of that job.
So it kind of lowers the importance
maybe of labor, or at least
the negotiating capability.
And obviously if there's
someone in another country
who could do that same job
and because trade barriers have gone down,
and monetary barriers have gone down,
people can relocate factories.
And so now all of sudden,
that could put pressure on wages in the US
or in richer countries
if someone in another country
can do it for cheaper.
- That's precisely right.
I mean, you take furniture
manufacturer in North Carolina
has managed to move to Latin America
or to Asia where workers to
do some of the same work,
or maybe not as efficiently.
But if they're being paid 1/5 as much,
it doesn't matter if they're
not as quite as efficient
in doing it.
We've seen this again and again.
If workers are being
replaced by farm workers,
they might be replaced by a machine
that can do what they would do.
And so maybe you used to have 10 workers
doing something manually or
with a factory assembly line.
Now you have two or three
workers operating computers
that make the same goods.
So those are true forces,
really important forces.
- And then just to be clear
on globalization, the academic
argument for globalization
is it actually makes the pie larger.
And so the consumers of those
services or those goods,
they might be able to
get it for cheaper now.
And also, what's probably
happening to your point
is those who own the
technology or have the capital,
they might be getting better returns now
because some of their
costs have gone down.
They're able to lower the price
so the consumers benefit,
but then they're able
to get better profit because their costs
have gone down even more.
- Yeah, and then I would
argue maybe even bigger
than either of those is
that it can bring good jobs
to people around the world.
You know, the last 50 years
have seen the greatest reduction
in global poverty in recorded history.
It hasn't been in this country.
It hasn't been in Europe,
it hasn't been in Japan,
but it has been in China, in India,
in large parts of Africa
and South America.
And so that is a very good development
for people who live there.
It's a good development for the world.
- And that's a good disclaimer.
And I can't wait to get
to all of the questions
we're getting, but I do,
I wanna go through all of the levers.
But this is, you know, as
we talk about these levers,
even though a lever may be contributing
in some way to inequality,
we're not saying that it's bad.
There might be other
positive aspects about it.
There might be ways to
mitigate those things.
So I think very quickly,
you know, people say,
"Wait, I like globalization.
"I don't like globalization."
But it's like, no, well
there's just some things
that it might be contributing.
Might have benefits, might have negatives.
Same thing about technology.
So let's keep going through these levers,
then I'll open it up to some
of these questions I'm seeing.
- That's great, I'm excited to hear them.
So I think then there are a set of things
where I would argue that
they are in many ways
policy choices that we have
made with either knowing
that we're making them, or
not necessarily knowing.
So one of the really key changes
is that we are no longer
producing educated, increasing
the stock of educated people
at the rate that we used to be.
There's a fantastic book by Claudia Goldin
and Larry Katz called
"The Race Between
Education and Technology".
And the title captures a lot this,
which is the example I just gave
where you went from 10
workers to two workers.
Those two workers, need
to have higher skills
in order to operate computers.
And if you think of the
long sweep of history,
you can kind of imagine this race
between education and technology.
The technology gets more sophisticated.
Are we producing the kind of workers
who can use the new technologies?
And there's been a huge slow
down in educational attainment
in this country,
even though all the signs
are that education pays off.
And I know people say,
"Wait, is college overrated?"
But as I like to point out
the people who say, "Is
college overrated?",
are often making sure that their own kids
are going to college.
So I think in terms of their own behavior,
people understand that
education is not overrated.
The unemployment rate
for college graduates
is vastly lower than for
non-college graduates.
The pay gap is near an all-time record.
College graduates live longer.
They are more likely to be happy.
They're more likely to be healthy.
And so but we haven't
done a good enough job
allowing more people to go to college
and really, to complete college.
So education is one issue.
- And actually, I'll double back
'cause there's a good question on that.
There's so many.
I hope we have a little bit more time
because I wanna get through all of these.
But there is a question that relates
to your point about the college education
which I think is interesting.
Mamata Barachariah says,
"I often think we can
get rid of inequality
"by educating everyone who wants
to be educated to your point,
"but don't you think this
crazy college tuition
"is one of the reasons behind
the massive inequality?"
And I also have heard the data
of those with a college education
make X amount more and
et cetera, et cetera.
But you know, it's not
a causality necessarily.
It could be a correlation.
And so we're getting a lot more people
to go into it.
They're getting into
large amounts of debt,
debt that's equivalent to the down payment
for their house in New York or California,
and probably buying a house outright
in a lot of the country.
Do you think, and maybe
that's not even captured
into some of these inflation numbers.
What's your sense of that?
- So I think it's
important to separate this.
The cost of college is a real problem,
but it's often, I think,
mis-described a little bit.
People hear, you know, it costs,
you're out in California,
I'm out in Washington.
You know, it costs, what, $70,000 a year
to go to Stanford, or to go to Georgetown
or to go to a school like that.
But it's really important to remember
those are not normal schools.
And not only that, but the schools
that charge that tend
to give large amounts
of financial aid to middle
and lower income people.
The typical college,
you know, like a California
State University,
or the University of
Maryland at Baltimore County,
or you name it,
these places cost vastly, vastly less.
They still cost a lot.
And I think they probably cost too much,
but you can't end up going
to one of those places
and end up with $200,000 worth of debt.
You know, the average debt
for college graduates is around $30,000.
That's not nothing.
But it's much, much less than the gap.
So cost is a problem.
But still, the truth is that
the vast majority of people
who finish easily pay off their debt.
Not everybody, but the vast majority.
College debt is a much
bigger problem for dropouts.
College debt is a bigger problem
for people who end up
with $15,000 of debt,
but don't get a degree.
We don't talk about that
crisis nearly often enough.
And then the only other thing I'd say
is there'd been some really
good academic studies
that have studied people
right at the threshold
of getting into the least
selective four-year college
in a state like Florida.
And the people who were
just above that threshold,
and who just get into the least
selective four-year college
and thus have a shot to
go to a four-year school
actually end up doing substantially better
in life over their 20s,
that's just as far as the data's gone out,
than people who just
missed that threshold.
And so while clearly part
of the value of college is correlation,
I do think part of it is also causality.
- Yeah, no, that last study
sounds really interesting.
And look, I can personally testify.
And I went to one of those schools
that I didn't think I could afford
'cause the MSRP price was very high.
But I was able to go even though my mother
made $16,000 a year in 1993.
So I can completely vouch for that.
But anyway, I interrupted
the various levers.
So we talked about globalization,
technology, and education.
Let's keep going.
- Yeah, yeah.
So I think you can combine
immigration and trade policy.
I think sometimes people
overstate the importance
of trade policy.
It's not like the trade deals we've signed
have caused all these problems.
But some of them really
have contributed to it.
And basically what we've
done is we have allowed
our both immigration and our trade policy
to create much more
competition in the middle
and the bottom of the labor market
than at the top.
So as you probably know,
it's like impossible
if you're a doctor from another country
to move to this country
and become a doctor, right?
You kind of have to start
all over at the beginning.
That's basically a big
trade barrier that protects
doctors in this country, right?
We say it's because we don't trust
those other medical systems,
but there are plenty of easy ways
to figure out whether doctors
are actually qualified
without simply rejecting
all of these qualifications
from other countries.
But we don't do that.
We make it really hard to
become a doctor in this country.
On the other hand, we've
had this absolute surge
of lower skilled and
medium skilled immigration
into this country over the last 30 years.
That's had some big benefits,
but it also really has created
additional competition.
And so when you look at our trade
and our immigration policies,
many of them really make sense
that they have put more
pressure on the wages
of people in the middle and the bottom
than at the top.
And then I would just
very briefly after that,
our tax policy.
Taxes on the very rich have plummeted.
The estate tax, income
taxes, corporate taxes,
every tax that the very rich pay
have basically plummeted
over the last 40 years.
And taxes for the people in the middle
and at the bottom which very important,
there tend to be the
payroll tax and sales taxes,
have just not fallen very much.
And so over the same
period that the market
has caused inequality to rise,
our tax code has exacerbated
those changes rather than
pushing against it.
- Philippe,
if you could bring up that animation
from David's Twitter account on how tax
has changed over time.
I think that really hits the point home
of what David's just mentioning.
There's an animation
that I really enjoyed,
and I actually made a video with it.
Yeah, here we go.
And what you see,
actually, you could explain this.
What's going?
It keeps repeating itself.
- [David] So this is the total tax rate.
You combine federal state and local
for the very richest families.
I can't remember.
You may see it on there as the top .01%.
You know, it's something
at the very, very top.
- [Sal] And what you're
saying that the right side,
the right data point is for the richest?
- Yes, thank you, sorry.
This is the whole tax.
Exactly right, Sal.
This is the country, right?
And so what you can see is in the middle
and the bottom, these tax rates
aren't changing very much.
They're staying within
a fairly narrow range.
That's the yellow line and the middle
and to the left.
But to the very right, where you're seeing
the very, very richest folks,
the tax rate is plummeting over time.
And I wanna emphasize,
this is actual tax rate.
This isn't the statutory tax rate
you pay on the last dollar.
This is you take someone's total income.
You then take all the taxes they pay,
federal, state, and local.
And back in the 1950s,
the very, very wealthy
were paying more than half
of all their income in taxes.
Maybe that's too high.
May well have been too high.
But it's plummeted to the
point where out tax code now
looks extremely flat.
There are fights among economists about
is it totally flat?
Do the rich still pay somewhat more?
But the data all points
in the same direction
which is it's become much much flatter
than it used to be over time
because we've cut taxes on stocks,
on other investments,
on inheritances, and on very top incomes.
And we haven't done that to sales taxes
and payroll taxes.
- [David] And just to make
sure people understand,
each, if you know at the horizontal axis,
the left is the lowest income earners.
And then you go to the 30%
percentile, 50th, 70th,
90th, 99th, and then 99.99th,
and then the top 400 people.
And then the vertical
axis is the tax rate,
effective tax rate to your point.
It's the total amount they paid,
I guess, divided by their income.
And to your point, you see how this flows
from 1950 all the way to
close to present times.
And yeah, the zero to the
90th percentile or so,
it's been pretty much the
same tax rate, give or take.
While it's really that
top 400 or the 99.99th,
or even the 99th percentile
that's come down a good bit.
And you know where it ends is fascinating
because it ends in 2018,
where the total effective
tax rates for the top 400
is lower than the 99.99th
which is lower than the
group right before it.
So how does that happen?
'Cause you know, when I
fill out my taxes I see
for every incremental more you make,
they're taxing at a higher amount.
So how is it possible that
the top 400 are taxed lower
than the 99.99th percentile?
- You may remember a number of years ago,
Warren Buffett got a bunch of attention
by saying that he paid a lower tax rate
than his secretary.
And Warren Buffett is very good
at explaining things pitifully.
And in some ways, that's
what he's describing
or what you see here.
One of the reasons is
that we tax investments
at a lower rate.
The people setting policy have decided
that if you tax investments
at a lower rate,
you'll get much more investment.
That'll benefit everyone long-term.
It hasn't quite worked out
the way it's been sold,
but that's the theory.
And so basically we tax
things like stock returns
at a lower rate we tax labor income.
And the people on the
far right of this chart
have much more of their
income in capital investments,
in stocks than they do relative
to the people in the middle.
- Yeah, and actually, I asked
that last question somewhat naively.
My last career, I was
a hedge fund analyst.
And I remember, I mean, my boss
who was a portfolio manager
and was the partner,
he felt guilty about it.
He, a great guy.
He actually would donate.
We once made a good
investment on an egg company,
and he felt so bad
because he's a vegetarian
that he donated all of his profits
for humane treatment of chickens.
But he felt guilty when
I learned about this.
I was paying a higher
tax rate as an analyst
because that was just income
versus what he was paying
because his income was classified
as capital gains income.
So he was paying roughly 15%
while I was paying 40 or 50%.
So it is a fascinating phenomena.
So we have a ton of questions here.
We're already at our normal end time,
but I wanna make sure we
get to some questions.
Let me know, David, if you've gotta run
or if you're running into another session.
But you know, one question
that's been coming up a lot,
even before COVID, you know,
Maya Sharma from YouTube asks,
"Do you think universal basic income
"is a valid solution in the long-term?"
- So I mean, look, this is a
great matter for debate, right?
And if we have any high school
debaters listening today,
I know that universal basic income
was one of the big topics
that was debated on the high
school circuit last year.
And it seems like it's actually
led to a lot of debates
that people really liked
because there are very good
philosophical arguments
on both sides of it.
What I would say is I
think that it really does
have some of the same incentive problems
that we talked about
with some of the issues
of societies that tried
to get rid of inequality.
I know universal basic income
isn't trying to get rid of inequality,
but I think when you look at
what really, really matters
to people, what correlates
with good health,
what correlates with happiness,
it often does involve work.
It involves the dignity that work brings.
It involves feeling like you're
part of something larger,
a larger project.
And so I have some real skepticism
about universal basic income
as our solution.
And I would be much more interested
in a set of solutions
where we really tried
to substantially increase the returns
to what are now low wage work.
You can do that through a
much higher minimum wage.
You can do it through a much bigger
earned income tax credit.
And then, maybe also looked at the idea
of rewarding people more for what are now
unpaid forms of labor, like
child care and elder care.
But to me, the idea of
a universal basic income
where we're paying people not to work,
despite everything we know
about some of the health
and psychological costs to not working,
and in addition, Sal, I
don't think I need to receive
universal basic income.
You know, I have a job as a journalist
and it pays me enough to live on.
And I really don't think our government
should be sending me a check every month.
And you know, there are millions of people
who also don't need to be
getting a check every month.
So I'm a skeptic of
universal basic income,
but I also see the arguments for it,
and I think it's a good thing
that we as a society have
started to debate it more.
- Yeah, and I think the argument would be,
if we received checks,
we'll also on the other
side be taxed higher,
so it would kind of be a wash.
But it's easier to implement things
like other social safety nets
created some of that disincentive
that you talked about.
While universal basic income,
you could still have a job.
But yeah, it's an interesting debate.
You know, one of the things you brought up
was minimum wage.
An economic purist would have
an argument against it saying,
"Hey, if you artificially
raise the market-clearing wage,
"then companies, your classic economics
"with your supply and demand curve,
"you're now going to create
this dead weight loss
"where you're not going to hire everyone."
There's also arguments that
it could create incentives
to move even faster towards
technology or globalization.
What are your counterarguments
to those arguments?
- I mean, I think there's
both the philosophical
and empirical counterargument.
There's been a real flowering of research
in the minimum wage over
the last 20 to 30 years.
And some of it shows that
there is a trade-off,
that if you put in place a minimum wage,
you lose some jobs.
The bulk of it shows
that the number of jobs
you lose from increasing the
minimum wage, within reason.
If we went to a $50 an hour minimum wage,
who knows what would happen.
We'd presumably lose a lot more jobs.
The losses are actually much more modest.
It's not the small, relatively
small dollar changes
don't immediately lead to
declines in employment.
There's a famous study looking
at New Jersey and Pennsylvania,
when one increased their minimum wage,
and the other didn't.
And so in terms of a
perfect economic laboratory,
you'd imagine that a whole bunch of jobs
on one side of the border
would move to the other,
but they didn't.
And so it turns out that
people make decisions
for all kinds of complicated reasons.
And the minimum wage,
often, for a business
doesn't lead to some radical
reduction in employment.
And it can lead, quite quickly,
to big changes in the quality of life
of people who are
receiving a 20% increase,
you know, $5 an hour to $6 an hour.
That's a 20% increase in pay.
And so I think if you
kind of look empirically
at the research, it suggests
that minimum wage increases
have done more good than
harm most of the time.
And then I think philosophically,
I understand why a society might say,
"Look, we're a wealthy society.
"We're simply not willing to have
"People living below a certain standard.
"And so we're gonna set
a minimum standard."
- Going back to either in minimum wage,
or even this notion of
universal basic income,
it does feel like the COVID crisis,
obviously, for no fault of their own,
many millions of people are
losing their jobs right now.
Restaurants are either temporarily
or permanently shut down.
Airlines, hotels, we could
make a long, long list.
To some degree, some of
what the stimulus packages
have done is starting to look a little bit
like universal basic income.
You know, every gets a $1,600 check.
Unemployment insurance is extended,
even if you're a contractor.
So do you think we're going
to naturally evolve there,
if this COVID crisis,
we have 30 million unemployed,
35 million unemployed.
People need to be fed.
People need to just be
able to pay their rent.
- I would be surprised if this leads us
to universal basic income
because sending checks to people
is extremely expensive, right?
The math, that's just the way the math is.
You're sending them to everyone
and they're not that small.
And look, we're still
gonna need to collect
the data on this,
but my instinct is that
these checks being sent
to everyone are not particularly
efficient forms of stimulus.
They are not a very good
bang for the buck way
to keep the economy functioning.
And I think there's a logical
way to think through this.
So many, many people,
most people have not lost their jobs.
Not only have they not lost their jobs,
many of them have had their typical daily
or weekly expenses plummet, right?
They're not paying for gas anymore.
They're not paying for the bus.
They're not paying for subways.
I don't know about you, but the amount
of money I spend on food has plummeted
because instead of picking up a $2 coffee
or a $6 sandwich, I'm
making myself peanut butter
on bread for lunch
'cause I'm around my refrigerator.
And so these people who
have kept their jobs
and had their expenses go down,
millions of them have
just gotten these checks.
And I think the evidence is showing
that they're not actually
gonna spend that money.
They're gonna save it.
Yet, now you take someone
who did lose her job.
For that person, the amount of money
that we are sending them
isn't nearly sufficient
to cover the rent, to cover food,
to pay for childcare.
And so we've got this
slightly funny situation
in which we've spent huge amounts of money
spent sending $1,200 to everybody below
a certain income threshold.
For many people, that's
more than they need.
And for other people,
it's not nearly enough.
And yet, it's so expensive
that if we wanted to keep
doing it in perpetuity,
we'd have to do massive cuts
to other social programs
like Medicare and Medicaid.
And so I'd be surprised if
it's where we end up long-term,
but lots of surprising things happen.
- And what would you, you
know, if you were emperor,
and you were going through
this COVID situation,
what would be your course of action?
You know, I've heard,
we had Ray Dalio on here
and I even chatted with him
a little bit afterwards.
And he's like by spending trillions
and just pumping it into the economy.
Yeah, this is increasing
the debt by trillions,
but the alternative is worse,
that we go into a depression
if we don't do that.
So would you be in favor
of that type of thing,
and if so, what is the metric?
Is it by writing these checks to everyone?
Which it sounds like it wouldn't be.
Is these loan programs which
seam to have been misused
a little bit by certain corporations.
So how would you try to tackle this?
- Austan Goolsbee, who's an economist
to the University of Chicago,
has this nice kind of series of lessons
that he put on Twitter, very quick,
about virus economics.
And I'm gonna misstate it slightly.
I apologize to Austan.
But the first rule of virus economics
is the only way to help the
economy is to defeat the virus.
And I think that's exactly right.
So I think we can't get back to normal
if people are still
fearing for their lives,
if they're fearing
particularly for their parents'
and their grandparents' lives.
It just won't happen.
And so I think the most effective forms
of economic stimulus
are likely to be something
like a massive program
to increase testing capacity.
All the estimates I've seen
that while the United States
is doing more testing, we're
not doing nearly enough.
A big program to increase quarantining,
a big program to increase
protective equipment
for medical workers,
a big program to increase contact tracing.
And of course, more research
into vaccines and treatments.
The good news is, while that
stuff's really expensive,
it pales in comparison
to the kind of trillions of dollars
that congress has spent to try to prop
up the economy.
So I think if you can
think of the economic stuff
as being necessary, but
really just being a prop
that tries to get us through a period
where we are investing enormous amounts
in crushing the curve,
and then allowing us to begin to operate
and also get a vaccine.
That strikes me as probably
the most effective approach.
But it doesn't really
seem to be the approach
that we're following as a society.
Instead, we've got this
scattershot approach
in which we're shoveling massive amounts
of money out the door which I do think
is probably necessary,
even if it's being done
in some inefficient ways.
And we're not really committing ourselves
to a huge national project
to increase testing.
And we're now starting
to open up even though
we haven't hit many of the benchmarks
that epidemiologists say we should hit.
And so I'd love to be proven
too pessimistic about this,
and there really is uncertainty.
But I feel like the most likely scenario
is that we're opening up too soon,
and we are gonna pay a price
both in terms of further outbreaks,
but also in terms of
our economy sliding back
into some kind of lockdown
and further recession
when the outbreaks come.
- Yeah, your point is no
matter how much stimulus you
put in, if people are
still afraid to go outside,
afraid to participate in the economy,
the stimulus will kind
of be just like pushing
on a string.
And I'll add one area
for anybody listening,
who's looking to spend a
few billion here or there.
I think internet access for everyone,
especially in this time, is
a very, very good investment.
I think it would pay many
good economic dividends.
And if you look at it
compared to, you know,
I've done back of the
envelope calculations.
I think you could get all the families
who don't have access today
some kind of basic internet
that you can use Kahn Academy on
for on the order of a
few tens of billions.
Which sounds like a large number,
but that's about 1% of the amount of money
that's been spent in the stimulus packages
just over the past few months.
- And to loop back to the main topic,
I mean, where is broadband
access a problem?
It's much more a problem
among lower income people
than upper income people.
- Yeah, one question, this is coming
from, it's going back to
one of your other levers
on the education.
I do wanna ask this 'cause
it's a thought experiment
that I've had with friends, you know,
just thinking about the issue.
Jenny Scoball from Facebook asks,
"But let's say everyone
gets a college education.
"Will there really be jobs
for all of those people?"
I mean you could imagine,
what if everyone had a PhD tomorrow?
Will there really be that many jobs
for those folks?
- So I love this question.
I get the version of this question a lot
when I'm out speaking.
I would actually ask people to flip it
and go not forwards in time,
but backwards in time.
Why is it necessary that everyone
gets a high school education?
Why is it necessary that everyone gets
an eighth grade education?
Why did we as a society
decide that 13 years
of public education was
essentially the minimum
that all people should have?
And that's not just a
hypothetical question.
There was a real, live
debate in this country
in the early 20th century,
and around the world about this.
And there were people who said,
"Come on, let's be realistic.
"Most Americans don't
need to go to high school.
"They need to learn to
read and that's about it.
"The high school should be for
the top echelons of society.
"It's a waste of time and
money to send ordinary workers
"to high school."
And then there were people,
the high school movement
which was a national movement,
a sort of national, local movement.
Maybe strongest at first in Iowa,
who said, "No, no, no,
education will pay off.
"If we create more educated workers,
"more educated citizens,
"our society will be healthier.
"And there will end up being jobs
"for many of those people."
And that second group really
won the bet in a route.
Europe for a long time
kept high school education
as more of an elite thing.
We went to mass high school education,
and it built so many
great American industries.
It built agriculture, to
have educated farmers.
It built Hollywood.
It build American manufacturing.
It built one industry after another.
And so if 13 years was the
amount of mass education
that made sense in the
early and mid-20th century,
why is it that we think that
number wouldn't have gone up
almost 100 years later?
And I think clearly, when you think about
how much more advance technology is,
that number has gone up.
And so thinking about 15 or 17 years
as the right number for
mass education makes sense.
And my instinct is if we got there,
much has happened 100 years ago,
we would find all kinds of job
we didn't even know existed for
our more educated citizenry.
And I don't think there's
a natural limit that says,
"Well, nine wasn't enough education.
"13 years was enough education,
"but anything more than 13
would end up being wasted."
- No, and obviously you're
preaching to the choir
when you're talking to me about it.
And the way I think about it is,
there is some logic to the
argument that Jenny is making,
that a degree doesn't
automatically convert into a job.
But from a societal scale,
and we use years as a proxy,
and we use high school
and college as a proxy.
But it's really can we
get people to that level
of critical thinking?
Can we get them to that level of skills
so they can leverage the
technology around them,
leverage, understand the
complexity of the environments
so they can either plug in to jobs
that already exist, or
will exist in 10 years.
Or even more interesting,
so they can create new jobs.
They can be entrepreneurs
at a small or a large scale
which is a job creation engine.
So it is an interesting,
I think on the margin
that argument, there is some.
Just the piece of paper by itself
isn't going to give you the job.
It's the fact that
you've actually developed
those types of skills.
And you know, we talk a lot
about this labor pyramid inverting now
where we need to get either people
to the top of that labor pyramid
into the knowledge economy
to get those skills,
or the inequality's gonna keep going.
So we're way over time.
This was a super, I feel
like we should continue.
This is part one.
I'm just commit you already.
- I'd love that.
(laughing)
- But thank you so much, David.
This was a really, really
stimulating conversation,
a conversation that I think people
need to be having more and be
having in kind of a, you know,
not politicizing it.
Just like, what are the facts?
What do we understand?
What works, what doesn't?
And nothing is all bad or all good,
but we should all be informed.
So thank you so much for participating.
- Thanks for having me,
and thanks to all of the viewers
for the great questions.
- Great, thanks so much David.
Well, thanks everyone for watching.
Obviously, these conversation go longer
when we're really having a good time.
But thank you for all of your questions.
It's a really important conversation.
Thanks for joining the live stream,
and I look forward to
seeing all of you tomorrow.